[Music]
so the show i did last wednesday i did
it at the resident yeah i love that
place because it's so nostalgic for like
any time we've done live [ __ ] and i i i
like warming up there but i don't know
if that's the place anymore yeah
comparing it to the dynasty typewriter
which i did on sunday it's like a proper
like stand-up venue resident it's like a
bar and everyone's like in those shitty
seats and it's hard to get them
comfortable i really want to say thank
you to everyone who came that show
because they took it on the chin i was
like so all over the place it was like
[ __ ] euphoric like i'm just like at
this room of people staring at me and
what a stupid way to come back in a
stand-up after almost two years yeah i'm
just gonna try an hour of [ __ ] [ __ ]
bold yeah everyone there was kind of
like
like they're laughing and you know
people say like shows was fine it wasn't
awful per se
except the people in the front row i
know they didn't like it why
they were just stone faced the whole
time no they did like two girls in the
front look like they were watching a car
accident the whole time like both their
faces were like
and i just kind of had this weird like
aggressive energy where one of the girls
was like you know
she said something and i was like when's
the last time you've been on stage she's
like i've never been on stage i was like
exactly so [ __ ] giving me [ __ ] for
and i just carried on and that's
probably not a fun way to watch the show
i forgot the comedian part where i roll
it off like a joke and make it fun for
everybody oh [ __ ] you yeah
stupid
anyways my parents yeah well yeah i went
on to some depressing ass [ __ ] after
that so like you know it was all great
because sunday was a night and day
difference sunday was really solid show
um and it was fun yeah i definitely feel
i should be doing more stand up nice
than youtube honestly really yeah okay
that's kind of where i'm at
i don't know man i've just made me think
like youtube has always been
not that natural so i'm kind of in a
weird i'm still gonna make youtube
videos but i definitely think stand-up
is more
where i should be so
well that's good yeah so it was it was a
good experience definitely odd to be in
a room full of people like that
you know like i'm sure it's the same
vibe like first time you went to the
brig probably it's like uh yeah
you know yeah it just feels like you're
not supposed to yeah
i don't know why it feels that way but
especially now with the old delta
creeping around yeah
you feel you feel any delta in that room
a little lambda and get some lambda
maybe no i
i didn't it didn't feel that lambda
in there it didn't feel lamb or dealt at
all how many people were there on sunday
sunday was like 200. holy [ __ ] yeah it
was that's sick yeah i thought it was i
thought it was only like 100 150 but
they're like yes 200 tickets and sold
out so that's sick yeah it was a good
time i was thinking what was bad on
wednesday was because it was just me
there's no opener so it's always like
the room is cold you know you have to
like get people in the mood so i thought
oh why don't i just bring someone from
the crowd to be my opener
you did that yeah so i like i brought
someone up and i told them a joke to say
and she committed no way commit what did
you say so i was like all right stand up
like introduce yourself she's like hi
i'm sarah
and then i was like whispering in her
ear like just quietly i'm like feeding
her the line she grabs the mic for me
she's like i don't know which one of you
[ __ ] needs to hear this but some of
you are too old to be listening to
olivia rodrigo
i was like damn
everyone's like
so i think like for my next show i'm
gonna write like a three minute set i'm
just going to try to find the most
uncomfortable person and hand them hand
it to him be like go that's gonna sit
and watch you just gotta write a bunch
of racist jokes for that that's what we
were joking about in the green room like
in the green room i was saying like you
know just make them i mean jamar
neighbors has done some [ __ ] like that
he got this white guy to go on stage and
tell like like a hood joke like
this was like
he's like say it say it
say it oh no the dude did it oh no
yeah
yeah it's intense with so
yeah we were joking like just write a
whole or just like not even like racial
[ __ ] but just [ __ ] that's like really
questionable it's like here's why the
baby was right
it's like excuse me now stay with me
here
and i want to switch it up every show
like just write a new five minutes and
be like have at it yeah i probably will
sprinkle something that's like you know
80 uncomfortable just to see what they
do i joked about nema doing it because i
thought it'd be really funny if i made
him
and i was like all right here's the
first line i don't know which one of you
[ __ ] needs to hear this the name was
like i'm not saying that
why
because he didn't want to call a room
full of women [ __ ]
it's not it wasn't all women
no it was all
it was all female every single one
yeah made that a requirement
no it just worked out that way
it's like it's like there were magic
seats as soon as men sat down they just
[Laughter]
turned turned into women
nah but it was it was a good time i'm
not saying the b word yeah yeah
i'm not going up there and saying the b
word
absolutely not
so i even more reason why i gotta make
[ __ ] dude i'm not gonna call a room
full of [ __ ] the b word you gotta be
joking me what the [ __ ] is this
oh yo
shout out shout out to this dude um
so yeah this is the first
wednesday night show this was uh
brittany broski ian smith and emmy
hartman
they were telling me some crazy stories
that
man uh you think nelk fans go hard
nah gay youth
no frat kid can hold a candle to gay
youth in terms of what
the types of drugs they do
when they party i mean
they were so they were schooling me on
uh poppers yep but specifically the part
where poppers loosen your [ __ ] and
you know
no one in particular but they were
talking about how some people
took poppers just to see if they could
[ __ ] themselves i'm like that's crazy
i don't want to hear about an elk fan
being like dude i drink a 30 brick last
night yeah this kid did poppers to [ __ ]
his pants
on purpose on purpose
in a gas station parking lot that's like
unhinged that is crazy there's no
audience there that's just doing it for
the thrill wow so can you imagine how
hard they go in a group
you know what i'm saying like i could
see gay youth just popping up at a party
but listen look look look here all you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yo that kid just [ __ ] his pants hand me
a happy dad yeah
he shotguns it
does a bunch of poppers and just shits
it out
all right i didn't see this tick tock
what do you what did he say eating a
wall
[Applause]
oh they're just sharing a turkey sub at
the show
just at noel it's just that's
it's just me
hell yeah oh there's an after got it
what'd she say hey guys we met noel and
i think
that's pretty good feedback yeah it's
good to know she out of nowhere in the
conversation because it was the three of
them came backstage for a minute to say
what's up and in in the middle of
conversation she goes uh get a grip i
start busting up laughing because i've
i've not heard that outside of like a
90s movie i've never heard someone
actually genuinely say you need to get a
grip
she said that to brittany bros because
she's like
and she said it another time and i'm
like this is a [ __ ] 824 film right
here yeah you do poppers to [ __ ] your
pants it get a grip yeah
get a grip i don't need poppers to [ __ ]
my pants
oh my god dude that's a tagline for a
popper you can sit right on it and get a
grip
you